MALE SPEAKER: Thank you all
for joining us this afternoon
for another Talks
at Google event.
We have today,
Doctor Don Johanson.
He's the discoverer of Lucy.
Ever since finding that
skeleton, that hominid,
his team has discovered over 350
skeletons of that same species.
So it's really an amazing story.
For over 40 years
he's led this program
and currently is working on the
Institute for Human Origins,
if I'm not mistaken.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: Of.
MALE SPEAKER: Of Human Origins.
Institute of Human Origins.
And so he'll talk to
us about that as well.
He is also speaking on behalf
of his book, "Lucy's Legacy."
So with that, please join me
in welcoming Doctor Johanson
to Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
Thanks very much.
It was so convenient to
have somebody pick me up
at my house in San Francisco
and drive me down here.
I actually finished my talk
in the backseat of the car.
But I'm happy to
have an opportunity
to speak at Google,
an organization
that absolutely
everybody knows about.
And if they don't,
they can Google it.
So I have had a wonderful
privilege of fulfilling
a childhood dream.
And I'm a professor at Arizona
State University, although I'm
living here and teaching
only online, which
I'll mention in a bit.
But I try to tease out
those students who really
have a passion for something.
And I think, probably, that's
the most difficult thing
in education in this
country right now,
is that so many students don't
have a passion or a commitment
to something at a young age.
And they flounder
or they say things.
They'll come into my
office and they'll say,
well jeez, there's nothing
left to do in the world.
And I was fortunate in
having a childhood dream.
I read a book when
I was 13 years old
called "Man's Place in
Nature" by Thomas Henry
Huxley, who was one of Charles
Darwin's closest buddies.
He was often called, as you
may remember, Darwin's bulldog,
because he was really the
proselytizer, in many ways,
for Darwin's paradigmatic shift.
And to use that
word carefully, that
was a really paradigm shift.
Can we turn the lights
down a little bit?
That would be great.
And he gave public lectures
throughout Great Britain
on evolution and Darwin's
"Origin of Species."
And he thought it was terribly
important to understand
our place in nature
and called his book
"Man's Place in Nature."
And one of the conclusions
that both he and Darwin came to
was that the idea of
natural selection,
a descent with
modification, and so on,
is not restricted just
to non-human creatures,
that it was also applicable
to the human species.
And they concluded that, based
on the similarities of apes
and humans, particularly
African apes
like chimps and especially
chimps and gorillas,
that we shared a
common ancestor.
That's one of the tenants
of evolutionary thought,
that there is descent
from a common ancestor.
And they predicted
at a time when
anthropologists,
biologists, geologists
were extraordinarily
euro-centric in terms
of understanding human
origins and pinpointing
Europe as the finishing
school for humanity.
And it wasn't
until the mid 1920s
that fossils that
were discernibly
on the human family
tree of great antiquity
began to be discovered.
And reading that book
as a young teenager,
I was absolutely
riveted by the idea
that we shared a common
ancestor with the extant apes,
and that there was, at least
at that time, the beginnings
of discoveries like Neanderthals
from Germany and France,
and also a cro-magnon,
as we call them,
Homo sapiens from
southern France.
And I wanted, as
a young student,
to be part of that search.
And I fortunately was accepted
to an undergraduate school,
University of Illinois, where
I studied anthropology and then
went on to the University of
Chicago where I did my Ph.D.
with a professor
who I sought out
who had an expedition
in Ethiopia, in Africa.
And I sort of talked
my way onto that dig
and spent my first year in
Africa in the summer of 1970.
So that's 45 years ago.
And when I first
entered the field
of what's called
paleo-anthropology-- the study
of human origins, not the
study of old anthropologists.
But when I first entered the
field of paleoanthropology,
we had about six
different species
on the human family tree.
Today we have upwards of
23, 24 different species.
So that the tree
of human evolution
has become exceedingly complex.
Today I've chosen to give some
of the biological background
to being human.
One of the questions that
we all ask ourselves,
whether you're philosophers,
anthropologists,
whether you're in
the tech business
or whatever, what is
it that makes us human?
And this is, of course,
the quintessential question
of anthropology, which is
the study of humankind.
And it's always been studied
from a cultural point of view.
People will say, well, you
know what makes us human
is we sing, we paint, we dance.
Every society has some
creation myth of some sort.
And so on.
These are, I think, really the
results of three core areas
that we're beginning to study.
Oh, and by the
way, if anybody is
thinking of tweeting anything,
I'll give you these addresses.
And central to understanding
what makes us human
is really this sort of
interactive evolutionary
dynamic between cultural
evolution on the one hand
and biological evolution
on the other hand.
I say that it's very
important to reinsert
the idea of
biological evolution,
because anthropologists
not far from here,
in a little school over
in Stanford, at Stanford,
had a schism in its
anthropology department
a number of years ago.
Because many of the
cultural-- social-cultural
anthropologists-- thought that
once culture comes in the door,
biology jumps out the window.
And that we are no longer
part of the natural world.
We are, as one anthropologist
Alfred Kroger wrote,
super organic beyond culture.
And I think we have
to really understand
the biological roots of who we
are and how that, in many ways,
set us up to be the
most dominant, the most
intelligent, the most
creative, and at the same time,
unfortunately, the most
destructive species we know
of in our solar system,
and perhaps anywhere
in the universe, which is
a rather provocative issue.
But certainly on this
planet, we are in control.
And how did that happen?
And I'm going to just touch
on this at the beginning
because the Institute
of Human Origins,
which is located at
Arizona State University,
grew out of an idea I had in
1981 when I moved to Berkeley
and founded this
research institute.
I wanted a place
that was dedicated
to the pursuit of finding
the cultural remains
and the fossil remains
of our ancestors
and try to fit them-- can these
lights come down any more?
MALE SPEAKER: Unfortunately
not for the video.
I'm sorry about that.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: Oh, OK.
I wanted a place
where we sort of had
a group of paleoanthropologists,
geologists, archaeologists,
people who were dating
rocks and so on,
came together under the rubric
of a single research institute
to pursue the past.
And in 1997, that organization
was acquired by Arizona State
University, providing us with
greatly expanded opportunities,
and also the opportunity
to leave descendants,
which is, after all, the
goal of all evolution.
We were now leaving students.
And before we were not.
And moving there,
we recently began
to move out into
other areas and try
to understand the
evolutionary foundations
of human uniqueness.
Because if you read
people like Steven Pinker
in "The Language
Instinct," and others
who are evolutionary biologists,
much of what we're looking at
must have some explanation
that can be rooted deeply
in the whole idea of
natural selection.
And that we are
who we are because
of that intangible force that
we call natural selection.
So the rubric that
we're working on, we
have about 14 different teams
working in different places,
everybody from psychologists to
field archaeologists and so on,
is to understand the
evolutionary interplay
of these three major insights, I
think, into what make us human.
We lead lives of extraordinary
cognitive complexity.
No other animal comes close
to the cognitive complexity
that we have.
And we have an extraordinarily
expensive organ,
which is called the brain,
which demands a lot of energy.
A different way of eating and
different foodstuffs and so on.
And the abilities to gain those.
And we communicate
through symbolic language.
No other animals do that.
No chimpanzees as
close as we can
get to ourselves, who
do sign and so on, talk
about tomorrow or
yesterday, or what's
going on in the next room.
So we are remarkably
unique in that regard.
Second, we have a capacity for
culture that is unsurpassed.
And particularly our
culture is cumulative.
And people here
at Google, people
in this part of the world, in
Silicon Valley, so to speak,
understand what that means.
Biological evolution
is glacially slow.
Over a very long period,
very minor changes occur.
But in terms of our
culture, whether it's
technology or what, our
advances are cumulative.
So once culture begins
to be our sort of savior,
in the sense that everything we
do is filtered through culture,
you have a growth
like that, which
is extraordinary and
unique and different
from any other creature
that we know of.
And thirdly, although it may not
seem like this when you open up
your morning news, humans
are the most cooperative
of any vertebrae on the planet.
No other creatures,
no other species
come anywhere close
to cooperating.
If we were a chimpanzee troop,
for example, male dominated,
of course, and a male chimp
from another troop came in,
we would kill him and eat him.
We cooperate more
extensively with each other
than anyone else, any other
species on the planet.
And at the moment, this
is a work in progress.
And maybe if I'm
invited back once we
have spent a few
years looking at this,
we may reveal some
very interesting deeper
understanding of what it
is that makes us human.
And interestingly,
this is a proposal
that is supported by the
Templeton Foundation, which
is a very religious
foundation as you may know.
Templeton supported
research in various fields,
but you had to tie it and try
to make science and religion
kind of fit comfortably
in the same textbook.
And there are no such
restraints based on us.
Well, as I said, there
were very few species
of fossils when I
first started working
in 1970, species of humans.
But today we have a fossil
record that takes us back
to about 6 million years.
We came from something, like you
see on the left here, much more
ape-like, with a projecting
face, a brain about the size
of a couple of cups
of coffee that we
have in the morning, about
380, 400 cubic centimeters.
Walking upright.
And these creatures
we collectively
call Australopithecus,
or ape man, as
they are sometimes called.
And they take us back to
about 6 million years ago.
And the one feature we
see that continues back
that far is upright bipedalism,
what I'm doing right now.
And freeing our hands
from locomotion.
And beginning to use them for
other ways of manipulating
the world around us.
It's interesting looking
at this because as we
grasp a branch on the
human family tree,
the roots all lead
back to Africa.
It's where we had a common
ancestor with the African apes.
It's where we first stood up
about 6 million years ago.
It's where we first began, in
the middle, to expand brains.
Lucy's brain was
about, as I said,
about 400 cubic centimeters.
Our brains are about
1,400 cubic centimeters.
It's where our ancestors
began to fashion stone tools
in a very regular
way at about 2.8,
maybe 3, maybe 3.4
million years ago.
It's a big debate
right now about that.
Where our bodies
were transformed
from ape-like bodies that
had very short lower limbs
to having very long lower
limbs, which is our lever
arm for getting around.
Right on up to the emergence of
Homo sapiens at 200,000 years.
So all these features that
we think of biologically,
and culturally in terms of the
birth of culture with stone
tools, and probably
culture before
that with things that don't
preserve in the fossil record,
all premiered in Africa.
So I'd like to look at no
specific place in Africa
as the cradle of
humankind, rather Africa
as a crucible where all of this
experimentation was going on.
I told you that I read Huxley.
I didn't read Darwin
till a little bit later.
He only had one, not very
interesting, black and white
diagram in his book.
Huxley had pictures of apes
and neanderthals and stuff.
And Darwin shied away,
as you know, from talking
about human origins.
He was particularly
worried about upsetting
Emma, his wife, who was a
very devout religious person.
But you have to read
"The Origin of Species"
to the last page, the second
to the last paragraph,
before he says, "light will
be thrown on the origin
of man and his history."
And that's all he said.
That was enough.
But it's true that
he tried to stay away
from this because he didn't
want to upset Victorian England.
He didn't want to be the
center of great controversy.
And yet later on, after chewing
on this idea for so long,
in 1871 he wrote a book
called "The Descent of Man."
And wrote up a
number of scenarios
of how we became human.
He and Huxley would go to the
zoo and they'd see chimpanzees.
And they'd see how
similar they are.
I'm sure everyone in this
room has seen a Jane Goodall
documentary or gone
to a zoo and looked
into the eyes of a
creature that is remarkably
reminiscent of maybe
somebody you know.
And there's no doubt
that they are not only
very similar in
their appearance,
but details of their
anatomy as Darwin and Huxley
examined their teeth and jaws,
are very similar to ours.
And from the work of people
like Goodall and many others,
there are certain behaviors that
are reminiscent of who we are.
They certainly experience
a wide range of emotions
that we would have traditionally
thought of as only being human.
And with the Human Genome
Project and the Chimp Genome
Project, chimps aren't running
that project, but the Chimp
Genome Project, we're
about 99% identical
in terms of our
DNA, which is one
of those homologous features
that really shows us that there
was a common ancestry there.
And it was not too far
distant in the past.
So there's no longer any
question among most people
that these two creatures shared
some sort of a common ancestor
somewhere about 8 million years
ago on the continent of Africa.
One of the features
in Africa that
has been so beneficial
to us is one
of the great
geological structures
on the planet, which is
the Great Rift Valley.
It runs all the way from
Mozambique in the south,
divides here, and continues
up through Tanzania and Kenya,
and up into the Horn
of Africa, which
is this area just up in here,
the little triangular area
known as the Afar Triangle.
And that was an area that
was really terra incognita
until the late 1960s.
I made my first visit there
with a French geologist who
had been exploring that area.
He had found bones
of big animals.
He didn't know what they were.
They were elephants, and
pigs, and rhinos, and monkeys,
and antelopes, and so on.
And during the
course of his work,
I met him in Paris at a
cocktail party and he said,
you should come with me.
And I did.
And this is the place where
I have worked since 1972.
You see the Rift Valley.
You see Addis Ababa,
the capital of Ethiopia.
The Rift Valley, this
is Lake Turkana, which
used to be lake Rudolf,
continues up here
into that very large triangular
area, which is, much of it,
below sea level.
It is where the Horn of Africa,
due to continental drift,
is beginning to move away.
And it is rifting the surface
of the face of Africa.
And very ancient
geological layers
are being resurrected,
because they're
being now eroded and exposed.
And this is a classic picture.
This is the first view I
had of the site of Hadar,
as it's called.
It's a local name, an Afar name,
the Afar people who live there.
And as far as you can
see in the distance
you see these
beautiful badlands.
And there are a
number of features
in there in the distance
which are very light colored.
And those happen to
be volcanic ashes.
And those volcanic ashes lend
themselves to argon dating.
So we can tell,
in a precise way,
how old these
geological strata are
by doing potassium argon
or argon argon analysis.
And they are very
horizontal, as you can see.
They have not been disturbed
very much by tectonics.
And in addition to that, you
can't see it quite as well
here, but they're
fairly fine grained,
which meant that
the deposition was
a very slow, quiet deposition.
It wasn't a raging river that
breaks up bones and distributes
them.
It records and preserves and
fossilized things in place.
And here is an aerial view.
I did a little
work for-- I think
this was a "NOVA" program--
a couple of years ago.
And took some photos.
We were very
fortunate, there was
a river running
right through here,
so we had a permanent
source of water.
We're out there for three
months a year, two and a half,
three months a year.
And I don't know how many
of you have spotted my camp,
but that's where we camped for
two and a half to three months,
in the middle of nowhere,
which means we have
to bring everything with us.
There's no Walgreens down
the street, or Safeway.
So it is a very remote place.
It is dangerous in
many, many ways.
Lots of snakes.
But also there are
two rival tribes
that live on either
side of that river.
And we've worked north
of the river, which
is towards the top of
the screen, since 1972.
We wanted to work
south of the river
but we're unable to because
of the nature of the people
there who like to shoot you.
So we've continued to
work there over the years.
And here's a closer view of
camp, what it looks like.
Various tents set up
for personal tents.
This is a work tent over here.
There's a kitchen tent.
There's an eating tent.
And a team of
scholars and students
will go out there for two
and a half to three months
to regularly search
for, excavate,
and hopefully discover
remains of our ancestors.
It is, as I said, a
fairly hostile region.
The Afar people, the first
year I worked there our camp
was burglarized in the middle
of the night by these people.
They didn't know who we were.
Fortunately we didn't get shot.
But over the years we've
made great friends with them,
and they are
regular participants
in the explorations
in these expeditions.
So we worked there between
the early '70s and 1980,
when Mengistu took over Ethiopia
and Haile Selassie was deposed.
And this is a typical group
of paleoanthropologists,
and geologists, archaeologists,
fossil pollen specialists, pig
specialists, elephant
specialists, kitchen crew,
and so forth and so on.
And I may be here talking about
these in these spotlights,
but if it wasn't for
this integrative effort,
this multi-disciplinary
approach,
I wouldn't be able to
tell you the details
that I'm going to tell you.
Work continues now at night.
The romanticism of the
kerosene lamps is long gone.
We have solar panels.
So we have electricity.
And we can charge
up our computers.
And we can communicate
with the rest of the world.
And sometimes people work
in the evening, as you saw.
And there's really no way
to find these fossils except
to go out, and walk, and
look, and walk, and look.
And to hope that your eyes will
fall on something exciting.
These fossils, this
is an elephant foot
that is eroding out of--
actually on top of it
was a beach sand.
Below it is deeper water
deposition, interestingly.
So it meant that the
lake was probably
receding at this point.
And you see a small
group of people
in the background for scale.
And you might spend three
or four or five days
in there with a team
of five or six people.
But this elephant, 3.4 million
years old, was found in place
and still, incredibly,
hard to believe,
it's still articulated.
So regularly research or survey
teams like this will go out.
And with a trained eye, try
to find these fossils that
have eroded out from
their ancient beds
where they've sort
of lain in suspended
animation for millions of years,
and give us better insight
into our early human ancestors.
Sometimes it's a
discovery a single tooth,
like this, that led to
an entire face of one
of these early
Australopithecus creatures.
You see in the background
a team of people
who are beginning to set
up a screening operation
and have cleaned this slope
totally of the loose sediment
on top and recovered
most of a single face.
In 1974 I completed my Ph.D.
at the University of Chicago.
And went out to Ethiopia for
my first major, full scale
expedition.
And had some National
Science Foundation
money that got us out there.
And that fall, in
November, at this locality
where you see the
people standing,
I made a discovery of a partial
skeleton, which has now become
more or less iconic, a skeleton
that was nicknamed Lucy,
after "Lucy in the
Sky with Diamonds,"
the Beatles song that was
playing in camp the night
of her discovery.
And one of our
expedition members,
Pamela, said, well, if
you think it's a female,
why don't you call her Lucy?
And she picked up
that moniker and has
been known as Lucy ever since.
Well, what did I find?
The first piece I
found was not a molar,
it was this little
fragmentary piece
of bone, which is the
elbow on the right side.
It is the ulna, the bone that
allows you to flex and extend.
As you can see, it's
like a little wrench.
It's not the one that
turns your forearm,
but the one that
flexes and extends.
And I kneel down
and looked at it
and knew virtually
immediately, from its anatomy,
there are features
in almost every bone
we pick up that
easily differentiate
between human and non-human.
The only thing it could
have been was a baboon.
It was the right size
for a fossil baboon,
but it didn't have the
right kind of anatomy
on the backside of it.
It had our kind of anatomy.
And then on the left, you see
a much younger and thinner me
with my graduate student
who is doing all the work,
but that's what
they do, wrapping up
each and every fragment
here in toilet paper.
We have these huge
boxes of toilet paper
that follow us to the field.
And marking each spot where
the large bones were discovered
before we started systematically
scraping and cleaning
and screening and so on.
So it was that single bone
that led to an excavation
where we had a small team out
there, a team of geologists,
anatomists,
paleontologists, and so on,
screening every
part of this hill.
And this is a photograph
of the first time
ever that these bones
were more or less
re-articulated after
3.2 million years.
We knew at the time that it was
older than three million years.
We didn't know how old exactly.
This is the French
colleague, Maurice Taieb
who was so generous in inviting
an international team to come
and work.
And we basically had a
French and American team
working there.
And this is the image
which has become so iconic,
a partial skeleton.
Unfortunately, the skull eroded
out first and rolled down
the hill and broke up.
So all we have are
fragments of the brain case.
But importantly, enough of the
back and the sides to give us
this cranial capacity estimate.
And a number of things
were important about her.
We had her pelvis, which is a
very fragmentary and fragile
part of the body, which tells
us a lot about locomotion.
And we had the knee,
and we had the ankle.
And it was clear from
the detailed anatomy,
working with an
orthopedic surgeon,
that in every one of these
anatomical regions so
important for
reconstructing locomotion,
this was a creature that was
fully upright and bipedal
on the ground as we are.
Clearly her legs
were very short.
If you compare the length of
the upper arm bone, the humerus,
with the thigh bone on the
lower right there, the femur,
they're almost of equal length.
As you see if you just
look at your own body,
your thigh bone or femur
is much longer than this,
because as I said, our
lower limb is our lever
arm for getting around.
She was clearly very different
in terms of details of teeth
and jaws and skull and so on.
And a distinctive new
species of Australopithecus.
And I named her after the Afar
people in the Afar region.
She is known in Ethiopia
by her own name.
She's known as Dinknesh,
which in Amharic means
you are wonderful.
But regularly driving around
Ethiopia in the countryside,
you'll come across something
like this, Lucy College.
There are Lucy cafes.
There are Lucy magazines.
The national soccer team of
Ethiopia, woman's soccer team,
is named Lucy.
There's a Lucy Cup in soccer.
So she's known
more often as Lucy
than as Dinknesh, which is
commemorated in this stamp that
was minted in 1985.
So this is more or less what
the complete reconstructed body
would look like.
And as you heard, we now have
many, many different specimens.
We have at Hadar itself,
90% of the sample that
represents Afarensis and
that's about 400 specimens.
And I know there are undescribed
in Ethiopia in the museum where
Lucy is stored, all
these fossils are back
in the capital in
the National Museum,
that there are another
300 or so specimens.
It is a species that lived
between about 3 million years
and 3.4 million years.
So it's one of the longest
lived species we know
of in the human fossil record.
We've been around for, as we
are now, maybe 100,000 years.
So her species was
an enduring species.
It's found throughout
eastern Africa, what
is today Kenya, Tanzania,
Ethiopia, out in Chad,
for example, in
North Central Africa.
And in 1976, Doctor Mary Leakey
who was in charge of work
with her husband Louis Leakey
at Olduvai Gorge, which
some of you may have visited
or certainly know about it,
came to visit me in the field
with her son Richard Leakey.
And bedazzled by the fossils
that we were finding.
We hadn't found
Lucy yet, but she
was encouraged to go back
to a site in Tanzania
where she and her husband
had worked in the late '30s
and didn't find any
hominids, didn't
find any human ancestors.
But it was about the same
age as the Lucy site.
And they found a trail of
human footprints impressed
in a volcanic ash that's
3.6 million years old.
And there was a volcano that
was erupting in that area.
It was a special
kind of volcanic ash.
It was a carbonitite.
It had a lot of
carbonates in it.
So it was at the beginning
of a rainy season.
And when it covered
the surface--
there was a light rain, because
you can see raindrops in there.
And a couple of
human ancestors that
were of the same species,
because we now have the teeth
and jaws of this
species at this site
called Laetoli, walked
across that surface
and left imprints of their feet.
And it's like all of us in
this room going to the beach
and walking in moist
sand, let's say at sunset,
then looking back.
That's what our
footprint looks like.
But this footprint is
3.6 million years old.
It's got a strong heel strike.
It's got a strong toe off.
It's got a transverse and
longitudinal arch to the foot.
And this was all predicted on
the fossils that we had found.
And it really documents in a way
we never thought was possible.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And what about Lucy herself?
What did she look like?
We know from the teeth,
the jaw, and now the skull
fragments we found,
that Lucy had
an ape-like face, with the
brain just a little larger
than a chimps.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: A piece
I did for a three part series
for "NOVA."
It's an animatronic.
-She may have had dark
skin and patchy hair
to protect her from the sun.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: We
know chimpanzees do this.
And I thought if chimps
can do it, why can't Lucy.
Termites are great
if they're roasted.
I don't like them raw.
If you ever go, get roasted.
They're wonderful.
-Walking upright freed her hands
to develop a more precise grip
than other apes,
more like our own.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
And the hand
bones that we have [INAUDIBLE]
certainly capable of finding
different [INAUDIBLE].
-And even with her
small brain, perhaps she
was beginning to have a more
human-like awareness of herself
and her surroundings.
Lucy and her kind must been
extraordinary creatures.
We know that they persisted as
a species virtually unchanged
for over a million years.
[END PLAYBACK]
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: So this
was a long lived species,
which is very important, and
geographically widespread,
meaning it lived in a series
of different habitats.
And more recently we have begun
to find more complete skulls.
For instance, this is a
beautifully complete 3.1
million year old, 3.2
million year old skull,
meaning the face, the
brain case, and the lower
jaw, of what a female of
Lucy's species would look like.
And it's allowed
paleoartists to reconstruct,
I think more accurately,
the shape of the face,
much more ape-like
as you would imagine.
And we've also begun to find
complete skulls of males,
which are considerably
larger than females.
So there was a lot
of sexual dimorphism
between males and females.
Lucy is, as people say,
probably the best known fossil
of the 20th century.
And has certainly
become the benchmark
by which other
discoveries are judged.
If something new is
found, like recently you
saw in the "National
Geographic" magazine,
they immediately say older than
Lucy, or younger than Lucy,
or more complete than Lucy,
or maybe an ancestor to Lucy,
or maybe one of
Lucy's descendants.
And she has become
part of our vernacular.
If you watch
"Jeopardy," occasionally
she appears on there.
She appears in
crossword puzzles when
the little clue
is human ancestor
begins with L, four letters.
My favorite one
appeared in, I think
it was, "Science"
magazine, where
Lucy goes to a cocktail party.
He says, oh, not the Lucy?
So she's become
very widely known
as kind of the ambassador.
And also, most
recently, I don't know
how many of you saw,
believe it or not,
Scarlett Johansson--
spells her name
with two S's as my parents did--
did this movie called "Lucy."
Anybody see this movie?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what, the other
day I was in this museum.
And you know what I found out?
-What?
-The first ever
woman was named Lucy.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
It's a very funky plot.
-Is that supposed to
make me feel better?
-Yeah.
No.
[END PLAYBACK]
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
So this movie
had been out for
quite some time.
And I was at a dinner
party in Santa Monica.
And someone said have you
seen the movie "Lucy?"
And I said, no.
And they said, you know,
it's about your Lucy.
And I couldn't believe
it, but there it was.
So as you heard,
Lucy is not alone.
Funny, a number of years
ago I was on an airplane
and talking to one
of those people
you can't stop talking to.
He's going to talk to you
whether you like it or not.
And he said, well, did you
ever find anything else?
So it was good question.
So we now have an
extraordinary insight
into the anatomy of virtually
every anatomical region.
And trying now to look
at micro-evolutionary
changes over time.
It seems to have been a very
stable species that underwent
very little change,
perhaps a slight increase
in body size over time,
but a very stable species.
And is the reference collection,
the go-to collection,
for all paleoanthropologists
who make discoveries now.
The first place they
go is to the drawers
where Lucy and the other fossil
from Hadar and the Afarensis
fossils are stored
in Addis Ababa.
We know an enormous
amount about this genus.
We belong in the genus Homo,
which is Latin for man,
as you know.
Yet we know much, much
more about the ape-men,
or Australopithecus, and
the diversity of species,
the specializations in
anatomy and behavior and diet,
than we know about the
origins of our own genus.
And most recently we have begun
to concentrate in areas where
we're finding sediments that are
between two million and three
million.
Lucy's species, is
I said, Afarensis,
disappeared at three
million years, which
was a very eventful
moment in human evolution,
and an eventful moment in
terms of climatic change.
Because at the three million
year timeline, time level,
there was this major
shift from a wetter,
more forested environment, to
a dryer, more open environment.
And we saw lots of
diversifications
in animals that we
think of traditionally
as savanna animals,
like baboons speciated
into a number of species.
Like the great diversity
of antelopes and gazelles
that make a living out
in these open areas.
And it is generally thought that
these earlier Australopithecus,
like Lucy, lived in more
bushy or more woodland,
not deeply thick
forested rainforest.
But certainly an
environment was different.
And at that time, one of the
great generators of change,
biological change with
natural selection working,
is climatic change.
So what happened was there
was a major change, that's
when Lucy's species disappears.
We see a whole proliferation of
different kinds of vertebrates
living in open areas.
And we see a major bifurcation
in the human family
tree between our
own genus, Homo,
which has emphasized
brain expansion,
and an increased diversity
of Australopithecus species
that are now beginning
to occupy a whole new set
of ecological niches,
as I will show you.
So the switch has turned
more to the origin
of man, the origin of Homo,
which a "New Yorker" cartoon so
neatly pointed out.
Oh yeah, well, what if I
were the first man on earth?
And there have been
some recent discoveries.
I'm happy to say that part
of that, part of those,
were made by my team.
This is a upper jaw.
This is the roof of your
mouth, right here, your palate.
And you can see from
the top that a chimp
and Australopithecus have
very long, from front to back,
narrow, parallel
side of tooth rows.
That's a feature we inherited
from our ape ancestry.
But our own species,
everybody sitting
in this room, Homo sapiens, we
have a much more parabolic arch
to our arch.
It is very deep.
If you put your tongue
in the top your mouth,
it's very domed.
Australopithecus and chimps
have a very shallow palate
from the bottom of the teeth
to the roof of the mouth.
And you can see how ours
is wider from side to side,
shorter from front to back.
And this is a 2.4
million-year-old upper jaw
that was found at
the side of Hadar
in much earlier deposits,
more recent deposits.
And was, for a long time, the
oldest anatomical evidence
that we have of our own
genus, not very much.
Yet it was associated,
interestingly,
with stone tools.
Tools, this doesn't probably
look like very much to you,
some of us have stones in our
driveways that look like that.
But there are features of that,
such as this flat platform
up here where it
was really struck,
this sort of bulb of percussion
here as the shockwaves
go through the rock.
And they're found in an area
where it's very fine grained.
So someone had to have purposely
brought in that raw material
and made the tools there.
And that's the
oldest association
between our own species and
our unique mode of adaptation,
which is culture.
Now most recently, a group from
the Institute of Human Origins
went off to a site up
here in the corner,
called Ledi-Geraru, which is not
far from the Hadar star there,
where Lucy was found.
And began looking at deposits
that I explored in 1972
that were not very fossil rich.
But I collected enough pigs
and elephant fossils from there
to know that this was
around somewhere between two
and a half to three
million years.
Pig fossils and elephant fossils
are very time diagnostic.
For instance, if we
all go out this weekend
and collect a
dinosaur tooth, you
know that rock is older than
65 million years, right?
Well, elephants and pigs
evolve very quickly over time.
And you can use them
as time diagnostics.
So a colleague of mine,
Kay Reed, at the Institute,
went out, got a
permit to work there.
And her team announced, you
may remember this spring,
the discovery of
what is the oldest
evidence for our own genus.
Again, it's fragmentary,
unfortunately.
We have a fragmented
mandible on the right
there, from the
top of that hill.
It was discovered by one
of our Ethiopian students.
Very interesting
developments in Ethiopia.
When we first went
there, there was no lab.
There were no people
interested in the subject.
Today, there's a
major commitment
by the Ethiopian
ministry of culture
that has built a fabulous lab.
There are now about 10
well-trained students
by our team and a
couple of other teams
who are Ethiopian
nationals, who are beginning
to undertake their
own explorations,
put their own teams together,
and make their own discoveries.
And appropriately,
this lower jaw
was discovered by one of
our Ethiopian students.
And there are features
of this, such as
the long, narrow
molars, for example,
and many other features
in that jaw, that
suggest that this
is the earliest
Homo at 2.8 million years.
Now it is most
interesting for me
because when I announced
Lucy in 1978, right
on the heels of that, I
published a major overview
in "Science."
And suggested the possibility
that Lucy's species, Afarensis,
is a generalized species,
meaning it was not very
specialized in any direction.
It could be the common
ancestor for our own lineage,
as well as other lineages
of Australopithecus.
And this helps
bolster that view.
Ethiopia has played an
incredibly important role,
mainly because of geology.
But now because there are
so many teams going there.
When I found Lucy in
1974, actually the year
before I found a
fossil knee, no one
had found a human fossil in that
region of the Afar Triangle,
that's 600 miles on the side.
And that led to sort
of a hominid rush,
like the discovery of
gold in California.
And other teams, who
became competing teams,
went out there and
started searching.
And the record in
Ethiopia ranges
from about 5.8 million
years ago, right
on up to the emergence of
Homo sapiens at 200,000 years.
So it is an extraordinarily
important and complete role.
Well, you may have all
heard that the new governor
of Kentucky, who's been
elected as a creationist, so
obviously these guys are
going to the Creation
Museum in Kentucky.
But this is the photograph
or the depiction we all
see so often every month
or so, "New Yorker"
has some form of this.
And it's an
inexorable march from,
as I say, ape to angel, because
we all think of ourselves
as being such angels.
But even Darwin knew that there
is no direct line from ape
to human, that the
evolution of all creatures,
whether they be plants,
insects, invertebrates, humans,
or whatever, is
basically a tree.
And he drew a tree in
his origin in 1859.
And that is, indeed, the case.
This is kind of my version
of the family tree.
Everybody in my field
has their own version,
so there's a veritable
forest out there.
But what I want
to point out here
is here is Lucy's
species, dying out
at about three million
years, and living for about
a million years of time.
We know her ancestor
at about 4.2 million,
there's no question about that.
And we know something
about her descendants
based on anatomy, this lineage
and these two lineages.
And this is the first time we've
been able to actually trace
lineages in the fossil record.
This was a group
of Australopithecus
that were devout vegetarians.
They had massive faces,
huge molars, big crests,
massive chewing muscles, like
the temporalis and masseter
muscles.
And they specialized.
And as the climate got drier
and drier in East Africa,
and as the antelopes and
gazelles and savanna baboons
and other forms of animals,
came into competition,
they ultimately went extinct.
They did not leave descendents.
So that part of the
hypothesis that I've
published in '81, which has
been fairly well established
with intermediate
forms between Afarensis
and their very derived forms.
And it's only just
recently, now,
that we've been able
to begin to fill
in this branch leading to Homo.
So it's a hypothesis.
It continues to be
strengthened by discoveries.
And what it does is it really
puts Lucy's species, Afarensis,
at a pivotal point on
the human family tree.
Where we had a fairly
impoverished family tree here,
to a very species-rich tree.
Many of those
species went extinct.
Neanderthals disappearing
about 40,000 years ago,
about 5,000 years after
we entered Europe.
And some other species
that went extinct.
So Lucy's particular
place on the family tree
is very important in
terms of understanding
the dynamics of
evolutionary change,
and ultimately the emergence
of all of us in this room,
Homo sapiens, about
200,000 years ago or so.
So this was one of those
moments-- oops, sorry--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: I had a
little nervous finger there.
In that movie, 'Lucy."
She actually goes
back and meets her.
Very funky.
But we all know where this came
from, This image right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: So, that is
more or less the story of Lucy
and her discovery,
her importance.
Important role she's played
in my life, of course,
as an anthropologist.
And this is my email if anybody
wants to be in touch with me.
I have a website called
becominghuman.org.
Because I think in many
ways we're not there yet.
We're just becoming human.
And I just released, 14th of
October, a MOOC on edx.org,
that is entitled
"Human Origins."
It's eight weeks of
lectures about-- I
guess there are about six
or seven lectures a week.
They are about 15 minutes long.
Illustrated.
I had been asked by Coursera
to do a course online.
And I really wanted to do
a course that was free.
I wanted people to have total
access to this, particularly
because of the third world
countries in which I work,
where they will never
have an opportunity, many
of these people, to take a
course in human evolution
or human origins.
And my Ethiopian
colleagues have already
written me, some of the
people working in the National
Museum, who have really
no formal education
in human evolution.
They are all glued to their
screen, because in this course,
they learn what
otherwise they would not
have available because this
course is absolutely free.
You have to enroll
at a certain time.
And if you want
credit, it's like $400.
There are 10,000 students
now taking this course.
It was the first
time it was offered.
It will be offered
again next March.
But these are
additional resources
if you would like to
follow up with anything.
And of course, I'm
available on email.
Thanks very much, indeed.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Any
questions for our talk?
Yes?
MALE SPEAKER: So
you described Lucy
between around four to
three million years ago.
Were there any other human
species or humanoid species
at that time?
In your diagram
there weren't any.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
The question is,
were there other
species of humans
living at the same time as
Australopithecus, Afarensis,
or Lucy's species.
This is a question that we
are debating at the moment.
An Ethiopian colleague
of mine found
at about 3.4
million years, which
means a couple hundred
thousand years older than Lucy,
north of where I work, a very
interesting foot skeleton
and partial limb skeleton
that has a divergent toe.
And that-- Lucy's
toe, or Afarensis,
we have a complete articulated
foot that we found one year.
And those feet
are like our feet.
You saw the
footprints and so on.
So he thinks that's
a new species.
He hasn't named it a
new species right now,
but I know in private
conversation with him
that he is on the verge
of putting together
an argument that it
is another species.
That would probably
be a species that
is a descendant of Ardipithecus,
which I haven't talked about,
which is at 4.4 million.
And while-- and it has a
very large divergent toe.
So there may be
two lineages there.
There is a discovery
by the Leakey family
on the west side of Lake
Turkana, which they have
given a new species name to.
And most people don't think
it's probably a new species.
But that may be another lineage.
I think it would be very
unusual if Afarensis
were the only species.
Even up as recently as 50,000
years ago on planet Earth,
we had Homo neanderthalensis.
We had Homo sapiens.
We had Homo erectus, very
late Homo erectus in Java.
We had Homo floresiensis, these
peculiar little hobbit-like
creatures that are found
out in the end of the Malay
Archipelago.
And perhaps these
denisovans that have been
recognized in genetic analyses.
So at just about
every point you had
three or four or five species.
But then there was a major
winnowing of those species.
And that is directly correlated,
really, with our emergence.
Wherever Homo sapiens went,
whatever species was there
as a human species, very
rapidly disappeared.
And there is an interesting
article by one of my colleagues
at the Institute of Human
Origin, Curtis Marion,
in the September issue, the
cover issue of the "Scientific
American" in
September, called "How
Humans Conquered the Planet."
And in there he makes a
case that the refinement
of the features that
we really consider
as modern human, symbolic
language, cumulative culture,
and significant cooperation,
division of labor, and so on,
really emerged in Africa, in
that very diverse, mosaic set
of environments.
Neanderthals had evolved into
a separate species in Europe
directly in response
to two things.
One was genetic
isolation, so there
was recombination, and
mutation, and natural selection.
But also a physical,
physiological, and anatomical
adaptations to a
periglacial environment.
They were living with glaciers
in the distance, three, four
miles thick.
And their anatomy shows that.
But he thinks that the things
that really make us who we are
today came out of Africa,
which alters dramatically,
and I've said this for
years, the early view we see
in "Time-Life" books on
early man of this upright,
white skin, French looking guy
in Europe, as the first humans.
Whereas, I think it was probably
a much darker skinned people
who came out of Europe and
displaced Neanderthals.
Brought about the extinction
of flores, floresiensis,
erectus, and so on.
So I'd be very surprised
if there were not
other lineages or other
species at the same time.
MALE SPEAKER: If I am
remembering correctly,
you said that Afarensis lived
to about three million years ago
and the earliest Homo
species was 2.8 million.
What is it that distinguishes
Homo from Australopithecus
that you can say, now
we've got a new genus?
DR. DONALD JOHANSON: Well,
I showed you the mandible.
And there are a number
of features in there,
the shape, the
elongation of the teeth,
the reduction of
buttressing of the anterior
portion of the mandible,
the particular place where
the, what's called, the
ascending ramus arises,
and the shape of the arch
in a parabolic fashion.
We don't know exactly
why those came about.
We think it had
something to do with more
flexion of the cranial basal
areas of the skull that
brought this face in
and shortened the arch.
And in relation to that,
it began to broaden.
But there are lots of
people working on that
trying to figure that out.
It isn't just the stone tools
that are found with them,
because that doesn't
define a species.
And the upper jaw I
showed you, I think,
was very convincingly different
from an Australopithecus.
So what we would like
to see, of course,
are cranial remains to see if
there's much difference in not
only cranial
capacity, but cranial
shape between Australopithecus.
Now the palate, if we look
at it in lateral view,
is not prognathic or projecting.
It's very flat like ours.
Our faces are very flat.
So there are those
subtle features
that all line up and
accumulate to convince us
that that Homo is very
different from Australopithecus.
Does that answer your question?
MALE SPEAKER: One more.
MALE SPEAKER: So you
mentioned that most
of the fossils of Lucy's
species are kept in the National
Museum in Ethiopia.
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
All of the specimens.
All of the specimens that
have been found in Ethiopia
of human ancestors now
reside in the National Museum
in Addis Ababa, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So, given what's
happening, like in Syria
and so on, are you worried that
someday somebody may steal them
or-- or what are we
doing to protect them?
DR. DONALD JOHANSON:
Well, I'm more worried
that there's going to
be a massive earthquake.
As you get earthquakes,
you know the Rift Valley
is very unstable like
California and the Western coast
and the Ring of Fire.
They are stored in
very substantial safes.
There are guards at the
museum all the time.
There is a trained group
of Ethiopian scholars now,
who are totally
dedicated to this.
Some of them are in still
Ethiopia teaching or working
full time at the ministry.
But of course, we never know.
I think there is no
anti-evolution movement
in Ethiopia like there
has been in Kenya because
of these radical Baptists
who have been going over
there and converting
everybody to Christianity
and saying that this evidence
needs to be destroyed,
sort of like the
ISIS point of view.
It would be very difficult
for anyone to steal these.
It would be very
difficult for anybody
to come in and destroy them.
But we never know what happens.
In 1940-- when was Pearl Harbor?
Was that '41?
All the Homo erectus, all
the Peking Man fossils,
were shipped from Peking to
the China Sea, South China Sea,
to save them from the invasion.
And they vanished.
They've never been found.
They never made it
aboard the USS Harrison.
So things like that happen.
Yet on the other hand, you
have the first Neanderthal
found in 1856 in the
Neander Valley, Neanderthal,
near Dusseldorf.
And that survived and
still is in Dusseldorf,
because it was kept in a safe.
And was the first
fossil Neanderthal,
the first fossil human
ever found in Europe.
But in addition to that, it
was the first fossil specimen
that gave us DNA.
They drilled into the arm
bone of this 1856 Neanderthal,
that nobody even knew
about genes back then.
Fortunately preserved.
Fortunately organic
material in it.
And fortunately getting
a DNA sequence out of it.
So it works both ways.
But I firmly believe
that these fossils belong
in the country of discovery,
and that it's incumbent on us
as scholars, coming in
at their invitation,
having this privileged
opportunity to come in,
to help them establish
these organizations
like a major laboratory,
like the National Museum,
to house these specimens.
And let's hope they do
continue to survive.
Maybe someday someone
will develop a method
to actually date the fossil
and not the volcanic ash,
for example.
That would be a
significant contribution.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
very much for speaking
with us today.
We'll have time for a
book signing afterwards.
So thank you for stopping by.